in this video we'll talk about cell
lines and cell strain
cell line is the general term that
applies to different populations of cell
that can be maintained in culture in
vitro
this is a portion of the intestine so we
can culture these intestinal cells as a
cell line and we can call it an
intestinal cell line there are different
features of the cell light such as they
can be maintained for an extended period
of time it should be retaining stability
in terms of certain phenotypes and
function
cell line is generally clonal that means
from the parental cell line there could
be
clonal progeny
when it comes to feature of the cell
line cell lines are generated from
subculturing a primary culture
and the cell line usually display
functional similarities with the primary
cell with certain degree of
dissimilarities in terms of genotype and
phenotype there could be modifications
cell lines are divided into two groups
based on the growth patterns
so finite cell line divides for limited
number of times whereas the continuous
cell line divides
for infinite numbers of time
finite cell line
has
limited division capability that means
they would divide for 20 or less 100
times for a finite number and they would
not divide anymore they would eventually
die
and the time
or the number of times they divide
before dying is governed by several
factors such as lineage differences
species
culture conditions and media conditions
now let me tell you that finite cell
lines are generally adherent in nature
that means they would stick to the
surface of the
culture plate
now infinite cell line in contrast can
grow for indefinite number of times they
generally divide faster compared to a
finite cell line
now these cells can eventually grow on
top of one another and they are forming
a multi-layered structure like a tumor
so infinite cell lines are pretty much
like a tumor or a cancerous cell
now generally normal cells are obtained
from tissue or organ
and you form a primary culture out of
them primary culture is then subcultured
after subculture you generate cell line
from that cell line you can select a
portion a subset of that cell line and
you can make them immortal and make them
a immortalized cell line or also you can
take the cells from a cancer cancer
patient and make a cancer cell line
which are immortal
so moral of the story cell strain is one
subset of a cell line
and they are selected
based on specific characteristics
cell strain will often undergo
additional genetic changes compared to
the parent cell line
so moral of the story or the take home
message is the cell strain is one kind
of subset of a cell line
the first continuous cell line ever
established was the gila cell line taken
from henrietta lacks who was a carcinoma
patient cervical carcinoma patient and
this was the first aneuploid line
derived derived from human tissue
and so far it has it has been used for
several purposes throughout the world
now let me tell you the example of cell
strain hmc one cell line is a frequently
used cell line to study mass cells so
basically this is muscle leukemia cell
line
so whenever we want to study some
aspects of muscle we can use this cell
line
now there are two variants of this cell
line hmc 1.1 and hmc 1.2 both these cell
variants are actually the cell strain or
a subset that are selectively
selected differently based on specific
mutations
okay let's talk about the applications
of cell line in research
in
molecular biology or cell biology lab
cell cultures are kind of bread and
butter technique every day people are
doing cell culture
now let's say you have
figured out a particular novel protein
protein x let's say and wanted to
understand when this particular protein
is localizing inside the cell
so you can clone that particular protein
in an expression vector transfected into
the cell line and then ask the question
where this gfp bound protein is
localizing and you can get your answer
by doing some microscopy technique in
this case you can see the protein is
localized in the nucleus because the
fluorescence is coming from the nucleus
this is one type of question there are
many other questions that can be
answered in a research settings for
example you have discovered a drug which
might have a anti-cancerous property how
do you test that you can use some
cancerous cell line and in one set you
don't treat it with anything and in
another set you treat it with this
particular drug and then you check
viability for both these cases if you
see a decrease in viability that means
your drug might be very efficient people
also create efficacy curves from this
particular
assays
there are many applications of cell line
in industry let me tell you one of that
so whenever you need antibodies you
order from the companies and the
companies generate antibody using
hybridoma technology which is a way of
generating monoclonal antibodies in
hybridoma technology a hybrid of
antigen specific b cell is fused with
myeloma cells how it is in specific b
cells can generate all the monoclonal
antibodies but they are finite they are
mortal so they has to be fused with
myeloma cells to produce a hybridoma
this hybridoma can be used to generate
monoclonal antibodies generation after
generation and that is how these
industrial companies can supply you with
antibody years after years
now let's talk about talk about some
clinical applications of cell line
so in clinical diagnosis several cell
lines are used one such example is to
detect presence of antinuclear
antibodies in patient's blood sample for
example if a patient has systemic lupus
arithmeticist they might have particular
anti-nuclear antibody in their blood
sample that can be detected using this
hep 2 cell line f2 cell line has all the
native protein arrays
and hundreds of antigen
which provides an ideal substrate for
ana detection so patient sample might
have these auto antibodies might not
have them using this particular cell
line and a combination of
immunofluorescence we can understand
whether the patient sample has
anti-nuclear antibodies or not looking
at the patterns
there could be several clinical
interpretations that can be made from
these immunofluorescence data so that is
why usage of cell line is crucial in
medical diagnosis as well and we give
just one example
but cell lines are very different from a
native tissue let me tell you why let's
say you have a portion of the brain a
neural tissue that would have different
cell types they would have they would
have abcd neurons different type of glia
astrocytes all your render sites etc but
a neural cell line would have isolated
or clonal population of only neurons
that means they would create synapses
but the way they create synapse synaptic
strain properties might be very
different from a native or a primary
tissue
that is why when using cell line we have
to think about some limitations and this
is why people these days generate 3d
cultures which mimics more like organ
and these are known as organoids for
brain
cerebral organoids are generated for
many other tissues organoid are
generated if you are interested you can
click on the i button to know more
there are several limitations of the
cell line as we have mentioned and we
should know this because when we are
using cell line for our own usage we
have to understand the limitations first
of all serial passage of sub culturing
leads to acquisition of several
mutations over time
that can lead to genetic drift and that
can cause several heterogeneity in the
culture at a particular time point so
obviously cell lines has many
limitations
cell lines never recapitulate the
entire property of a primary culture it
recapitulate only certain aspects
immortalized cell lines might have
different chromosomal abnormalities
aberrations and mutations so they do not
permit
uh studying several biological process
and we have to be very careful when we
think and design our experiments using
these cell lines
so you can get notes and flash cards
regarding this topic and many other
topics in my facebook channel in my
facebook page so please share the link
of my facebook page with your friends
you would get many dynamic flash cards
which would help with your preparation
and understanding as usual don't forget
to like share and subscribe you can
support my channel on patreon super like
or if you're an indian viewer you can
support me via beam upi you can scan
this qr code to pay me
anyway
my courses are also present in academy
which is india's biggest online learning
platform you can use my code ap 10 to